Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a science fiction drama film
called “Finch.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts with a brief montage of earth
in ruins. A solar flare damaged the ozone layer
ten years ago, causing temperatures to
climb to 150 degrees Fahrenheit. Planet
Earth has deteriorated into a mostly inhospitable
wasteland, burned by UV radiation and vulnerable
to catastrophic weather phenomena. Finch, one
of the few survivors, is shown at the start.
He is a robotic engineer equipped with a suit that
protects him from the heat and the UV rays.
Like any other day, he's scavenging for
supplies with his robot Dewey. When he walks
inside a store, his measurements suggest that
UV radiation levels in the area are quite high.
Meanwhile, the robot picks whatever is left in the
store. Finch is then seen taking some dog food.
After leaving, he marks the area so that he can
keep track of the places that are scavenged.
In the next scene, Finch travels through
a deserted town that has been ravaged due
to the ozone layer's depletion. The UV rays
make it impossible for people to go outside.
Hence, the majority of the city has been
evacuated. Suddenly, Finch’s suit emits a
warning that a storm is approaching. He spins
the truck around and slams on the accelerator,
while the giant storm chases him. Luckily, he
manages to reach his underground laboratory,
which was formerly owned by the firm for which
he worked before the catastrophe hit.
Later, we get to know that Finch is dying
from tuberculosis . His dog cum pal, Goodyear,
is waiting for him at his big house. He hugs and
kisses the dog, then prepares the food he found
earlier. While Goodyear eats, Finch merely sips
on a drink as the supplies are running out. Later,
with the help of an AI, Finch uploads
basic instructions on his new project
like ‘how to care for a dog’ , ‘how
to do household chores’ and so on.
Since Finch loves Goodyear more than anything, he
is working on creating a highly specialized robot
to care for him after his death. Finch has been
conducting a lot of study on UV rays and radiation
exposure. Later, he removes Dewey's eyes and
attaches them to his new robot. After turning on
the robot, he starts transmitting data to it.
After a lot of failed attempts to communicate, the
robot finally nods its head, symbolizing that he
is understanding what Finch is trying to convey.
Finch is overjoyed by the reaction from the robot
and the fact that he's made it one step further.
He also plays with his dog believing
that he might soon have a new friend.
Finch then tells the robot to mention something
about himself. The robot says that he has some
rules, such as not harming humans, but the
most essential rule is that in Finch's absence,
he must take care of Goodyear at all costs. All
of a sudden, the power goes out. Finch heads out
to repair the wind turbine. He connects the
cable after which the lights are restored.
Inside, the robot names himself Jeff.
Meanwhile, a gigantic storm is seen coming
their way. Finch comes back and connects Jeff to
the weather station so he can make a forecast.
Jeff says that 4 different storms will approach
them in the next 24 hours and they will not be
able to avoid it. He also forecasts that it will
last roughly 40 days. Hearing this, Finch believes
that they have to leave the place soon. He also
presumes San Francisco as their best option.
Finch then starts to build the robot’s full
body. After finishing it, Finch increases
the robot’s transfer rate and starts teaching
him how to walk. Following a bit of practice,
Jeff successfully starts walking. While Finch
is happy with the progress, Goodyear dislikes
the robot and doesn't trust him at all. As the
storm gets nearer, Finch starts packing all the
essentials and also unplugs Jeff’s data transfer
at only 72 percent. Because of this, Jeff is not
fully developed and hence acts like a child.
Finch calls Dewey to join them but forgets that
he has removed his eyes. Hence, he attaches
a camera so that he can finally see again.
The four then climb on an RV and start making
their way to San Francisco. At the start of
the ride, Jeff is extremely curious as he
tries to learn everything Finch does.
For the time being, the group has successfully
managed to evade the storm. They then stop by
a deserted town. Finch wears the UV protection
suit and calls Jeff to join him outside. He then
starts teaching Jeff basic instructions on how to
scavenge and also about the hazards of the sun.
The duo also has a moment of fun when they pop
some popcorn out in the sun. Yes, that’s how bad
the sun has become! The fun however soon fades
away when Finch notices the storm approaching
them. He gathers everyone and tries to outrun the
storm, but it eventually catches up to them.
Finch rushes outside with Jeff and orders him
to help him tie the RV with wires. After Finch
gets tired, Jeff takes charge and successfully
completes the task. Finch then gets inside the
RV and secures it. Soon, the massive tornado
hits, and all the wires begin to snap one after
another until only one is remaining. Luckly,
the storm passes away and everyone is fine.
Finch appreciates Jeff’s good work but gets
disappointed to learn that the front tire of
the vehicle is damaged. They have a spare tire but
do not have a jack to lift the vehicle. However,
Jeff simply lifts the vehicle using his sheer
strength and tells Finch to change the tire.
The next morning, Jeff attempts to communicate
with Goodyear saying that he is trying to learn
the dog language. But Finch wakes up and makes
him understand that it will take some time for
him and Goodyear to be on good terms.
Later that day, a board points out that
San Francisco is 1522 miles away. Finch is stumped
when Jeff asks him to explain the notion of trust.
Hence he just shares his own life story.
He mentions how he alone solved the software
problem during a project, but gave the
credit to the whole team. In this way,
he was able to win their trust. All this
time, Finch’s health keeps deteriorating.
Then stop at a restaurant, where Finch
vomits blood. Realizing that he doesn’t have
much time left, Finch takes Goodyear inside the
restaurant and starts playing with him. Meanwhile,
Jeff is toying with the RV. He puts on songs while
he tries to drive. Because of his clumsiness, he
lets go of the handbrake, and the RV hits a car.
When Finch confronts Jeff, he acts all innocent.
He then reverses the RV, only to crash it again.
A furious Finch demonstrates what happens to his
skin when he steps in the sunlight. He then
screams at Jeff, telling him that his only
job is to take care of Goodyear.
After they leave the restaurant,
Finch decides to teach Jeff driving. At first Jeff
is clumsy as usual, but he soon gets a hang of it
and starts driving smoothly. Finch is pleased
at this but the doggo still remains skeptical.
At night, they stop by the road to camp. There,
the beautiful northern lights can be seen as
The ozone layer is no longer present. Jeff
suggests that they could drive at night,
mentioning that daylight is hazardous.
However, Finch teaches him that hungry
people approach at night and it's dangerous.
In the morning, Finch vomits blood and is also
shivering. Jeff takes good care of him, asking
if he should call the doctor. After that,
they continue their journey. When they arrive in
a major city, Jeffs wakes Dewey and the duo head
out to scavenge for supplies. They come across
a hospital which looks looted but Jeff is yet to
learn that, so he continues his way inside.
When Finch wakes up, he discovers that both the
robots are missing. He knows that trouble lies
ahead so despite being extremely weak, he suits
up and sets off to find Jeff and Dewey. Someone
is watching him from the shadows. Upstairs,
Jeff is delighted to find food, medicine and even
a fancy jacket for himself. Meanwhile, Dewey finds
some snacks, but doesn’t notice a bear trap near
it. As he reaches for the snacks, the bear trap
rips him apart. After a distraught Finch finds
him, he apologises and turns off his power.
Soon, Finch hears a rumbling sound and finds
Jeff as well. Finch stresses that they cannot
stay at the place any longer as it is not safe
for them. Both of them then make a run but Finch
is barely managing to stay on his feet. When
they reach their RV, they immediately speed away
but a vehicle starts following them.
After reaching a bit far, Finch hands over
the steering to Jeff telling him not to make any
mistakes from now on. He also notices the car
still following them. They turn off the headlights
as Jeff is able to see in the dark. While the
mystery car still pursues them, Finch suggests
Jeff to step on the accelerator and speed up.
As they are driving into a storm, Finch
grabs the wheel and steers it off the road.
He intends to use the underpass instead. Despite
Jeff trying his best to explain that the height
of RV is higher than the underpass, Finch does
not listen and eventually it crashes and the
RV’s solar panels are destroyed. After the crash,
Jeff uses his strength to push the RV inside.
The car that was following them approaches.
However, It stops for a little moment,
and then drives away. After knowing that the
people have gone, Finch rushes outside and
discovers that all of their solar panels have
been damaged. He starts blaming himself for his
poor judgment and also mentions that he cannot
repair it. Jeff assures him that he can take
them to San Francisco but Finch snaps at him to
stop talking. A furious Finch then returns to the
vehicle while Jeff stands outside in the rain.
After a little snooping, Jeff comes inside and
tells Finch that he thinks they'll make it
to the Golden Gate Bridge in San Francisco.
Meanwhile, Finch shares another story and relates
why he doesn't trust people and how he discovered
Goodyear in a bag. He mentions that Goodyear
was terrified and alone, and how he promised to
protect him at any cost. Finch adds that hunger
can turn any good human being into killers,
but it turned Finch into a coward as he kept
hiding while some young boys killed a young
girl and her mother in the supermarket.
The next morning, another board points out
that it is 480 miles to San Francisco. Jeff is
on the wheel while a weak Finch rests. Suddenly,
Jeff notices a butterfly on the windshield. He
pulls over, awakens Finch up, and points to the
butterfly. Finch gets up and stretches his hand
out, only to find it unaffected by the sunlight.
He then steps outside and feels the sun;
the UV radiation has decreased to the
point where it is no longer a threat.
He sees a flower and another butterfly and
laughs heartily. As they continue their journey,
they get past flowering plains. Later, Finch gets
dressed and they decide to have a picnic in
the sun, something he hasn't done in over a
decade. Finch then shares some more memories
of his past, while wishing that he could make
more of his life. Hearing this, Jeff excitedly
gets up and explains that if they leave now,
they will reach the Golden Gate bridge in about 18
hours. However, Finch says that he can't make it.
A saddened Jeff then promises to take
care of Goodyear when he’s gone.
After that, Finch brings out Goodyear's ball and
the two engage in a game of fetch. He then hands
the ball to Jeff and explains that this is one of
the first stages in creating trust with the dog.
The two then have a brief moment of fun when
suddenly Finch starts coughing up blood. His
white suit is covered in blood now.
When Jeff asks if he can help him,
Finch responds he has already done so. He
then shakes Jeff’s hand, and they hug. Here,
Jeff is visibly upset and we can see that he has
emotions too. Jeff then assists Finch into the RV,
where he lies down. Goodyear consoles
Finch while Jeff packs their belongings.
Finch pats his beloved buddy in the back one more
time before passing away. The two then burn Finch
in the plains along with his UV suit.
After they are done mourning,
Jeff continues with the daily routine of Finch and
feeds the dog. Later, they play fetch again. With
Jeff, Goodyear starts to feel safe and begins
to change. Jeff also feels that Goodyear is now
his responsibility, and they set off again. He
befriends Goodyear, who finally embraces him.
When they finally arrive at the Golden Gate
Bridge, Jeff constructs a memorial for Finch.
There, they find several messages
left by people for their loved ones,
letting them know where they can be found.
This concludes that there are more survivors;
with the possibility of family members
being reunited. In the final scene,
Jeff sticks his drawing of Finch, Goodyear,
and himself on the fence. The two of them
then leave for somewhere else.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.